[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا الكرام نحن في انتظار كلمه
الامير محمد بن سلمان حقق صندوق سمارات
العامه خلال الاعوام السابقه انجازات
استثماريه واقتصاديه ضخمه تمكن من خلالها
الوصول المستهدفات استراتيجيه مهمه حيث
ضاع في صندوق استماره العامه وصوله الى ما
يقارب تريليون مليار ريال سعودي بنهايه
عام 2020
اعلان صندوق الاستثمارات العامه السعودي
عن استراتيجيته او وجود الصندوق راح يساعد
ان شاء الله على جذب هذه الاستثمارات ورفع
الثقه
مليون الف وظيفه في خلال خمسه سنوات قادره
استثمارات تنمويه اعلن ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان عن تصاميم مدينه
لاين في نيوب
[موسيقى]
لاين ثوره حضاريه كبيره جدا
اعلن ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان عن انشاء مدينه نيوم الصناعيه
اوكسجون
تاريخ فيها بلحظات الالهام هذه طبيعه
المكان الذي ستشكله
الافكار في هذا المكان ستغير العالم
اعلان الامير محمد بن سلمان رئيس مجلس
اداره اليوم طبعا عن انشاء تروجينا هذه
الوجهه العالميه للسياحه الجبليه الجديده
وجهه عالميه فريده طبيعتها ساحره
وتقنياتها فائقه شموخ يسكن قمم جبال نيون
مرحبا
جبان نيو